madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur le secrétaire d'État
aux Affaires étrangères au commonwells
et au développement
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
mes chers collègues parlementaires si
c'est un moment inédit que nous fait
vivre votre Majesté en nous faisant
l'honneur de s'adresser dans cette
hémicycle du Sénat à la représentation
parlementaire française pour la première
fois dans l'histoire multicéculaire de
nos deux pays un souverain britannique
va prendre la parole devant le Parlement
français
réunis dans sa composition bicamérale et
dans sa diversité politique
vous me permettrez de souhaiter la
bienvenue à la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et à vous tous chers collègues
députés qui siégé aujourd'hui parmi vos
collègues sénateurs
j'ai le plaisir également de saluer les
membres de la Chambre des communes et de
la Chambre des Lords qui se sont joints
à nous ce matin
vous avez tenu cher à réserver au
Parlement français le discours public
que vous prononcerez dans votre visite
d'État
c'est dire l'estime nouer entre la plus
ancienne des nations parlementaires
le Royaume-Uni et le parlementarisme
français
de l'abh corpus à la Charte des droits
le Royaume-Uni a ouvert la voie au
parlementarisme moderne
il faut avoir assisté comme
Châteaubriand
aux séances du Parlement britannique
pour s'exclamer dans les Mémoires
d'Outre-Tombe je le cite la liberté
contenue dans les limites de l'ordre
sembler ce débattre à Westminster fin de
citation Chateaubriand
la démocratie parlementaire
et j'en suis persuadé le plus sûr
antidote pour juguler les passions
politiques
et entre nous deux pays c'est bien de
passion dont il s'agit
parfois ennemis souvent alliés
longtemps concurrent le Royaume-Uni et
la France ont distillés
dans les ordres le Royaume-Uni fut un
refuge pour tous les Français contre un
exil et fut même un temps en juin 1940
où la capitale de la France c'était en
quelque sorte transporter à Londres pour
édifier ensemble une digue commune au
totalitarisme et à l'empire de la
brutalité
dans l'adversité se réalisait après bien
les tumultures c'est bon
l'Angleterre toujours
sera sœur de la France écrivait Victor
Hugo
aujourd'hui
alors que nous nous apprêtons à
commémorer au printemps prochain le 80e
anniversaire
du débarquement en Normandie
le déclin du Royaume-Uni demeure
intimement lié au continent européen
le brexit SIR n'y a rien changé
votre nation est un acteur primordial de
la sécurité en Europe
le Royaume-Uni et la France
deux nations de tradition militaire dont
l'une à l'autre
n'a jamais été envahi
sauf par Guillaume le Conquérant
français avant l'heure
oui le Royaume-Uni et la France se sont
à de multiples reprises éprouvées mais
toujours respecter depuis longtemps de
cordiales il y aura bientôt 120 ans elle
se tiennent côte à côte
elles sont aujourd'hui fidèles à leur
vocation en se portant ce cours de
l'Ukraine
agressé et meurtri
vous avez choisi cire comme la reine
Elizabeth II lors de sa visite d'État en
2004 de vous rendre au Sénat
au-delà du respect porté à la reine dont
je tiens à saluer la mémoire nous
voulons y percevoir un hommage au
territoire de la République que les
souverains britanniques ont aussi
assidûment parcourus et que le Sénat
représente un hommage à cette diversité
de territoires et de paysages dont la
préservation vous tient cirque tellement
à cœur et qui constitue l'une des
grandes causes de notre temps
les collectivités territoriales de nos
pays au travers notamment des communes
on
noué de relations entre elles
elles sont le socle le plus solide de
notre amitié
à travers les territoires
ce
cette idée n'est pas mienne elle
provient du plus français des historiens
britanniques
Théodore Zeldin dans l'histoire des
passions françaises et concédons le
oui concédons le à notre fierté
nationale il faut bien un historien
britannique de grands talents pour
réussir à décrypter les méandres des
passions françaises
rares sont les pays européens qui comme
le Royaume-Uni et la France ont préservé
une même aspiration
à considérer le monde dans sa globalité
et qui sait autant de liens de
solidarité avec les pays les plus
vulnérables
avec un constat partagé
l'exerceration des fractures Nord-Sud ne
sert que les ambitions de puissance des
gouvernants qui les attisent le
néocolonialisme est de fait d'État
prédateurs et non des colonisateurs
d'hier
la France et le Royaume-Uni disposent
des ressorts nécessaires pour proposer
un autre horizon des coopérations
équilibrées la sécurité un développement
qui soit durable et une attention
particulière à la jeunesse de ces pays
le moment le moment me semble venu de
rassembler les grandes familles du
Commonwealth et de la Francophonie pour
qu'elle ait un langage
commun ce que préfigurer avec hum le
général de Gaulle qui se confiait à
Winston Churchill et je le cite
plus vous progressez en français et plus
vous comprenez mon anglais
cette formule me va assez bien aussi
pour mon anglais
[Applaudissements]
si
Sa Majesté la Reine Elizabeth
avait déclaré en 1996 lors d'une autre
visite d'État
celle du président Jacques Chirac à
Londres et je la cite
s'il est vrai que nous ne conduisons pas
du même côté de la route
il est tout aussi vrai que nous avançons
dans la même direction
de ce trait d'esprit
qui nous paraît à nous Français si
typiquement britannique
nous distinguons une vérité essentielle
nos chemins peuvent être différents il
divergent même parfois mais par une
constante qui défie les règles de la
logique et de la géographie de Londres
il nous ramène toujours à Paris et de
Paris à Londres ainsi s'incline le
cartésianisme français devant l'humour
et l'esprit britannique
sirent maintenant à travers les
parlementaires réunis c'est la nation
française tout entière qui vous écoute
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]